like put here i believe something did
create this earth
but yeah i don't know whether there
still is a god and you are a tick tock
creator yeah
imagine someone watches your stuff yeah
and let's suppose
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
all right assalamu alaikum what happened
tonight brothers and sisters we're here
at tottenham court road station
we're here with famous tick tockers yeah
uh what's your name jake
jake joe max max
yeah as known as big boss yeah be
careful to this guy okay so today we're
going to be talking about
who's an atheist and who believes in god
well i was baptized but i don't believe
in god
okay i sort of believe in god sort of
it's like mixed it's not
you you're agnostic you're atheist what
about you i don't believe in god
sometimes i deep it and i'm like yeah
just thinking about it but
yeah i don't think about it too much
okay so okay let me ask you a question
here okay
what do you ever wonder your purpose
like why am i here like who put me or
where am i going
yes sometimes sometimes yeah but not a
lot
no no no so what what makes you know you
said sometimes you deep it like
what makes you like hold on a second
actually there's maybe there's more to
this life
what the moments that you have in life
that makes you think that you know hold
on a second is there something
bigger than this no i sort of just think
like yeah
where did i come from how was i made
from like before
my parents and stuff like that's like
the first human beings how are they like
put on earth
that's what i think about okay
interesting the aim of life is just like
to earn money and then we'll die
eventually so every clothes and all this
we buy it's not really ours because at
the end of the day everyone's going to
die eventually so the aim is just to
make money and enjoy that's a good point
you know you show me your training show
them again
you know why let me tell you guys yeah
guess how much you paid for these
trainers
watch this what are they called uh
jordan dunks jordan dunks yeah okay
like dunks donuts not joking guess how
much these words show them to the camera
250 pounds yeah so now let me tell you
something here
do you think these trainers are going to
make you happy
no they won't make me happy at all okay
so what was the reason you bought them
uh to show them off okay to show them
off here okay so do you sometimes think
that
we give ourselves a purpose by living
for others look i came to islam about
eight years ago yeah i wasn't born a
muslim yeah
so i used to live a lifestyle of wanting
to show off his role like i'll go to the
gym
yeah i would i want to drive certain
cars and all of this was because i
wanted to show off to the girls
or show off to my family members whoever
it might be to get it but what i
realized
is that that doesn't bring me happiness
yeah so i had to ask myself a big
question okay
because once you live the life of you
know having the money and the cars and
all this kind of stuff
you ask yourself what next because
you're going to come to a point we're
going to hit a wall and be like
okay is this it so when was talking
about for example money and cars etc
these are not your ultimate purpose yeah
because if you think about it our
trainers
our the chain that you wear to the
jumper that you wear to the back that
you have
they all have a purpose somebody made
them with a purpose and a design they've
given it a design
i'm trying to say so you said you're
agnostic yeah do you believe that all of
this was created by nothing
no i think like it's created by people
building it
okay but then yeah when i say like i dip
it i think like how was the material
made
and stuff it's going back from that yeah
exactly
so the universe we know there was a big
bang yeah
that's where it began from so did the
big bang come from nothing
can can it come from nothing no big bang
from a meteor that has come and hit the
earth which has come from far away
obviously
okay where did that come from the
universe somewhere somewhere in space
okay what caused that to hit
our whatever the big bang way
no problem but want me to go that way
because it's it can't be random events
there's millions of meteors going all
around the world
obviously and some are going to hit and
some aren't going to hit nothing okay
but the point is that's like saying for
example what's the chance of someone
winning the lottery
compared to what's the chance of you
winning the lottery yeah there's a whole
different probability in that yeah
what's the chance of someone winning
well definitely someone's going to win
it but what's the chances of
you winning in it so the thing is the
fact that for example our universe
is one of the is the only planet that
there's life in it and
for example to the oxygen that we have
to the water to for example the way we
function
there it's impossible for us to think
that random events random things yeah
like we're all made out of dna here
atoms here
these random blind beings yeah things
that have no purpose
how can they give rise to us we have a
consciousness we think i'm trying to say
so do you not think that there must be a
creator or something that brought us to
be
yeah but like i can't really think about
that i don't really
understand it enough to think about okay
how my consciousness was even
like put here i believe something did
create this earth but
yeah i don't know whether there still is
a god and you are a tick-tock creator
yeah
imagine someone watches your stuff yeah
and let's suppose that you never show
your face and someone says ah
this person it's random random things
are making this
you as a content creator i'm a content
creator as well
you would feel offended that people
benefit from your stuff they watch your
stuff they share your stuff
but they deny you yeah i would feel
offended 100
so how do you think it is for god we're
not saying god has feelings where
the thing is this it's a disrespect do
you get it yeah no it's
a disrespect completely if you're just
if you're just saying like that's not
them or whatever it's just
you they would feel bad on their part
exactly so imagine everything that god's
given us on this earth i'm not going to
keep you guys know i know you guys need
to go yeah
imagine everything that you have you
enjoy the food that he gives the oxygen
that you breathe
the sleep that you have you enjoy all of
that and you did totally disregard it
yeah
like he doesn't you get it yeah now you
say like that i sort of put it
into perspective and like yeah you like
you get all these things
from what like there must be something
that put it there for you to enjoy and
have
and like you just said to joe like his
tick tock page and stuff
like he's got all of this people benefit
from it they like it
but they don't believe he's real and
like for the smallest like
bit of respect you could give him that
is to believe that he is a real person
exactly so like you've got to give
respect to god or whoever put this here
check this out check this out jk i'm not
going to hold you guys i know you guys
need to go yeah
imagine as a content creator i take your
stuff and people start thanking me
yeah i would hate that you hate that now
people were like
gods he put like the materials yes but
the people here they believe in him yeah
yeah no
you don't believe in him you ascribe it
to someone else you say you know what i
believe for example this is
i thank the you know those people to go
on statues or people that say
jesus is god and stuff like that is
christians say that yeah we believe that
is the biggest form of blessing because
what you're doing is
the credit that god deserves you're
thanking things like in the creation you
get it
i'm going to end on this note guys here
i'm going to open the quran i'm going to
read one verse i'm going to open it
randomly yeah and i believe
i'm going to this is a message from this
because we believe god almighty this
from god almighty yeah okay
and i believe this is a message to all
of us okay you ready i'm gonna try to
open a random place
all right shopping around the place and
point point our verse
any verse okay let's read that verse
yeah okay so this is
zuma it says
you